yep and Disney's crusade to translate
their beloved Animated Classics into
live-action movies here we are we have
hit Beauty in the base they can catch
that Jungle Book lightning in a bottle
again I'm all for two let's review
[Music]
beauty on the piece I don't think the
Beauty and the Beast is a live-action
adaptation of the Disney classic beauty
in the beach but how can they found
their stride with Cinderella they were
like let's just make a live-action
version of why people like the animated
movie it worked oh like hey let's do
that with Jungle Book with some new
twists and oh it worked and now we're
doing Beauty in the base it was Beauty
to be you get a lot of that feeling but
you liked about the animation some new
stuff so now here we go
Emma Watson plays Belle she's a dreamer
she's a bookworm she doesn't really fit
in with anyone in her town because she's
smarter than everyone through a series
of events Belle wives have been a cursed
castle with the beasts and all of his
friends in there are now appliances like
bran little toes are not really
appliances Deneb appliances background
so hangers clocks candle Lumiere
Cogsworth you remember him so now you
know love conquers all and Disney magic
and beauty and the beast inside what I
like about this movies first of all
everyone in the movie does a great job
for the role Emma Watson was great as
Belle she has a great singing voice
they're just some of the notes in the
classic we're drawn out you're like whoa
that's a masterful singing voice right
here this one the note isn't drawn out
as much and it falls before it does in
the animated version I don't know if
that's a call were there like well we
just want to make the song different so
it's not the same thing or Emma Watson
goes do to try my best
I pulled the world I was going to retire
after Harry Potter here I still am but
in either case she was really good as
well Luke Evans is Gaston Gaston is once
again the douchebag you remember Gaston
Bane Gaston is wonderfully played by
Luke Evans who looks like he was born to
play Gaston but this friend loved food
played by Josh GAD which is funny
because it just recently came out with a
like oh by the way Lefou in this movie
is gay for me I was like that's actually
kind of crazy that anyone thought look
food was ever straight well let's look
foo every straight I didn't know that
come on let's be real the food was
always gay indication he was bizarrely
heavy-handed and his affection for
guests on more than the animations just
that he always had a comment that was
like I was like you are the neediest
person I've ever
in my life and again in the movie he
addresses the fact that people say he's
needy so hey I guess it worked and the
musical numbers are as you remember them
they maintain and hold the same magic or
the beauty in the base song while
they're dancing in the ballroom dude
that just it hits you right there y'all
that's right I love this it does it
gives you the feels it's a very touching
story maybe is in the eye of the
beholder
Stockholm Syndrome and all the sweet
stuff in lines there are a couple of
moments that are new to this movie some
of which feels like I like seeing that
but there were some moments in this
movie where they change it up from the
animation to be different what is it
seeing the animation or bases like five
as you could stay in there and stop he
just yells it's not really in here
though the lines in here but doesn't
have the impact and there is a scene in
the animated version where the beast
lets out this huge blood-curdling yell
like the dude is just in emotional pain
you're like oh that dude is hurtin and I
feel that because that's a very painful
roar this movie's like we're not gonna
have him do that we're going to have him
sing a new song I'm all down for a new
song but it really detracted from the
moment I meet him just screaming in
emotional pain is more impactful than a
musical number couple moments like that
happen in this movie that's just to say
the animated version is very good it was
in fact nominated for Best Picture in
the Oscars that year but this
live-action Beauty and the Beast is
still very excellent the very faithful
adaptation of what you loved about
Beauty and the Beast of old and now is
you have a live-action version of it
with a couple of differences but still
like action version of it in the end
guys Beauty and the Beast was generally
speaking what I wanted Beauty and the
Beast to be I thought everybody in the
movie played their parts well for their
characters I prefer the animated version
to the live-action version I don't know
if that's nostalgia but I do genuinely
believe objectively to my core that a
couple of the moments just had better
timing and they just utilized all the
pacing perfectly in the animation it's
as good a live-action bidding the beast
as I could have asked for I will say
Beauty and the Beast is certainly worth
watching and certainly worth buying on
blu-ray makes me hopeful for all the
other live-action Disney movies they
want to do hardest one will probably be
Aladdin because who would be the genie
just nobody so guys Beauty and the Beast
have you seen it what did you think
about his reviews a little
so what's that point my question is what
Disney animated movie do you want to see
translated into live-action next
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]